benifer packing on the pda in italy
i'm excited about it seriously check out
that smile on jlo's face
she's sitting on ben's lap as he kisses
her cheek
the rekindled couple looked oh so in
love as they dined at a restaurant in
italy
our store says they were at los scolio
for three hours and
get this shared two makeout sessions
that lasted
20 minutes each like whoa it feels
really good and it's really nice but i'm
so happy jlo has been sharing all sorts
of sexy snaps from her european getaway
with ben
and ben's bff matt damon playfully
talked about the pair at a stillwater
premiere
days ago there's a lot going on in
france right now did you call ben up and
say what gives man why didn't you give
me an invite
no i think that's a private trip i don't
think i'd be invited on that one i might
be a bit of a third wheel
matt also had this to say about the
couple in a new interview with jesus and
miro
so what's it like having your boy have a
relationship that's all over the news is
that like weird
well yeah it's it's weird but i have to
say which you know the press was
particularly terrible to them like 18
years ago
so what's nice is that it's been nice
at least they're being nice this time
around ben and jen have a
whole lot of history the pair dated back
in 2002
and got engaged later that year i think
we had chemistry
as actors from the first moment we
started working they met while filming
their movie
geely i'm sorry do we know each other
not yet of course the pair ended up
calling it quits shortly before their
wedding
in 2004. it was my first like adult
heartbreak
we were about to get married it didn't
work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak
like you know just one of those breakups
that really you know
it was like a tough one for me fast
forward to now
the two are very much back on and a
source recently told et
quote they have insane on another level
chemistry
they are both super passionate and our
head over heels with each other
just like they once were i want to give
it away but it has a very good
you